-You look good, man.
You're a stud.
-Alright, alright.
-Come on,
Travis Kelce in the house.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How we doing, guys? Man.
-Couldn't have happened to
a better dude, man.
-This is
a dream come true, Jimmy.
This is sweet.
-Come on, bud.
-Are you kidding me?
-We met each other probably
almost a year ago, right?
-Yeah, just about a year ago.
Vegas, baby. Vegas.
-We were at -- Justin Timberlake
had a golf tournament.
-Mm-hmm.
-8:00 a.m. golf tournament.
-Yeah, 8:00 a.m. golf tourney.
-And we play -- And we never met
each other, hung out.
We hung out all day and we
totally hit it off, I thought.
-I couldn't
get away from you, man.
-I know. I was kind of a fanboy.
I kept following you around
like, "Hey, Travis.
Hi, bud. Hi, man."
Yeah, exactly.
-My favorite part
was "Mustang Sally," baby.
-Oh, dude.
-He jumped up on the stage
and gave us all --
-We had to rock it out.
We had to scream.
I was going nuts.
But, dude, we were hanging out.
You were so fun.
I've got to say --
How does it feel now?
This is the second time
you won the Super Bowl, bud.
-Man, I'll tell you what --
the first time
was one of the most emotional
like, "I finally did it."
-Yeah. Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
-And then we lost to
the Tampa Bay Buccaneers,
got our tails whupped
pretty good against them.
So that was a low moment.
And then it kind of
build back up.
And to get this one, to be back
on the mountaintop, man,
I'll tell you what, it's
the best feeling in the world.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, buddy.
You were so good.
-Oh, yeah.
Especially to do it with
the guys we did it with,
the ups and downs through it,
the adversity of the season.
It was a lot of fun, man.
-But also to do it with
Patrick Mahomes.
That's where I met you.
You guys were together.
-Oh, yeah.
-Was that a plan for you guys
to hang out on the off-season
and be kind of best friends.
-I think it just
happened organically.
It was just like, "Hey, man,
what are you doing?
You're about to go to Vegas
and play golf?
Alright, let's do it."
-Really?
-And it's been awesome since
he's been in Kansas City.
He doesn't get enough credit for
the type of leader that he is,
the type of just personable guy
he is in the locker room.
And it's on and off the field.
He does unbelievable things
in the community in Kansas City.
And that's the kind of,
you know,
vibe that I like
to be around, man.
-Yeah.
-And it was just kind of like
magnets when he got to K.C.
-Yeah, but I --
'Cause I was thinking,
"Oh, maybe this is a plan.
Maybe Andy Reid said, 'Hey,
you guys should be best friends.
Just go play with each other.'"
-Just compete and --
-Go to a movie.
Go to a movie, go do something,
go watch Netflix for an
afternoon or something, yeah.
-It started with the,
"Hey, do you drink beers?
Do you drink beer?"
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Because I like to drink beers.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-It sounds like
we could have some fun.
-Yeah, exactly.
And you guys bonded.
I just thought it was great,
and you have great chemistry
and it's real.
It's not fake at all.
I witnessed it for a weekend.
It was, like, so cool to watch.
The parade was yesterday.
-Yes.
-So I want to thank you
for being here today.
-Oh, man,
I almost didn't make it.
-I know, I know, I know, I know,
I know, I know, I know.
I was actually --
I was thinking about --
I was going to call Jason
if you didn't show up.
I'm like, "Dude, get over here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Jason, get over here right now."
Everyone's always
asking about your brother.
But that must have been just
a bizarre thing
to be playing in the Super Bowl
with your brother.
-Man, it was -- You know,
you always dream growing up that
you're going to one day
be in the Super Bowl,
especially when my brother's the
reason why I even play football.
Like -- Yeah, exactly.
When I was growing up -- I'm two
years younger than my brother.
And that's about as drunk as
I was at the parade right there.
That's me
-That's during
the parade yesterday?
-Yeah, that's me.
That's full parade form
right there.
-Oh, my God.
I thought this was when
you were a kid.
This is yesterday.
-No, this is yesterday.
Yeah, growing up in
Cleveland, Ohio,
I followed his footsteps
in a lot of areas,
sports being one of them
and football
definitely being one of them.
And you always imagine, you
know, playing on the same team,
but, man, I'll tell you what,
the way the football world
and everybody embraced my family
and me and my brother
playing against each other --
for the first time, two brothers
playing against each other
in the Super Bowl.
It was cool to break
that barrier and see my family
and all the light
and getting all the glory.
Man, it was beautiful.
-I mean, 'cause when you were a
kid, like there --
You're probably in your front
yard or something?
-Yeah, probably
3 or 5 years old, maybe.
-Yeah, and what's
the big Super Bowl there?
Like, you're like --
I don't know what it is.
Like, Thanksgiving?
-Exactly.
-Like a Turkey Bowl
or something?
-Exactly.
-Yeah.
-Just excited we got costumes
and we can look like
football players.
-Yeah. Here's you
and your brother
at this year's Super Bowl.
-Alright, now.
-Yeah.
All the cameras
got you right there saying,
"Hey, I love you, bro."
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I also got to give
a shout-out.
Your mom has been the cutest
for this whole ride,
'cause everyone is like,
"Who are you rooting for?
What son do you like better?"
You know, all that stuff.
And she's been so cool.
And I've got to show you
the jacket.
Here's what Mama Kelce
was wearing.
-Split right down the middle
right there.
-Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You see the red side's
on that left right there.
-Yeah.
-It's right there
next to that heart.
She knows. Mama knows best.
Mama knows best.
-I mean, mama knows best.
-That right shoe looked way
better than the left shoe.
No offense, guys.
-I know this is tough for
The Roots to be --
'Cause they're just such
Philly fans.
But you know what?
No one picked -- Look at this.
No one picked you guys to win at
all, none of the experts.
-The experts.
-The experts say that, yeah,
the Chiefs were out of it
way back in April, I think.
We lost a
big-name wide receiver,
one of my favorite teammates
ever, Tyreek Hill,
and they thought that it
was just -- it was over for us.
And that's why being on
that mountaintop, man,
it just felt
that much sweeter, man.
-But did you feel --
[ Cheers and applause ]
'Cause watching the Super Bowl,
I thought you were out.
I've got to be honest.
I mean, that second half
and when Patrick
started limping off the field,
I go, "Oh, gosh."
-10-point lead, man.
Don't give Pat Mahomes
10 points,
because he will just floor it.
-Really?
He's like, "Don't tell me no."
-Yeah, he got --
It will probably go down
as one of my favorite speeches.
At halftime,
he got electric, man.
He lit a fire in everybody's
tail just to, you know,
want it that much more.
And when you can do that
with a group of men, man,
that's a special human being
right there.
-Yeah, and you got everyone
hyped up and you came back.
It was an unbelievable comeback.
-Second half
was a lot of energy, man.
A lot of energy.
A lot of passion.
-We have a big announcement that
we're going to announce here
on the show tonight.
I'm very excited about this.
You're going to be back
in our building in a few weeks.
Can you say why
you're coming back?
-Yeah, for sure.
I mean, growing up,
I was a huge, like,
Farley, Ferrell, Fallon
kind of guy growing up.
And, yeah, I used to watch
"Saturday Night Live"
with my mother.
And it's an absolute honor
and a privilege
to be hosting "SNL" March 4th.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Come on, buddy!
Come on, bud! Yes!
It's going to be great!
-I am so nervous for that.
Oh, my gosh.
-You are going to be so good.
I was talking to Lorne today.
I'm like, "Oh, he's so charming
and he can sing and he's fun."
And it's so good.
-You think that about me?
-I do. Yeah.
-Thanks, man.
-I know. Yeah, yeah. I do.
-You're making me blush, man.
-Oh, it's amazing.
But Kelsea Ballerini
is musical guest.
-Yes. Yes.
-So it's going to be a hot show.
Congratulations on that.
-Thank you very much.
-You know, it's interesting
that -- I was just --
It's interesting that
I brought up singing,
because I know that you
do some karaoke.
And --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How did you know?
-It's kind of out there.
-How'd it get out there?
-There was one song that has
been very important to you
during this playoff run,
and I thought maybe,
if we can convince you...
[ Cheers and applause ]
We've got The Roots.
We've got the best in
the business right there.
-Fellas, do you mind?
♪♪
Kick it!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Whoo!
♪ You wake up late for school
and you don't wanna go ♪
♪ You ask your mom "please,"
but she still says "no" ♪
♪ You miss two classes
and no homework ♪
♪ But your teacher
preaches class
like you're some kind of jerk ♪
Sing it with me.
♪ You gotta fight ♪
♪ For your right ♪
♪ To party ♪
-Whoo!
-♪ You gotta fight ♪
-♪ For your right ♪
♪ To party ♪
-Travis Kelce, everybody!
-Whoo!
-Catch him hosting
"Saturday Night Live"
on March 4th with musical guest
Kelsea Ballerini.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show."
Stick around!